hello and welcome to this video playing
kofta with black ok i bring the
symmetrical Oh III mmm now came that
will probably need to a chiro broken
power of this is not bad right in 3some
playable on transposition to a entirely
different type of position so bad many
players probably with black won't be all
that knowledgeable him it can also take
really taking us better but ok I can rep
you for here but I think this is bad
yeah I think there's some theoretical
problem with itself let's not waste too
much time
I think you just cannot take it like it
takes takes Knight b5 and something
something like that okay just try to be
a bit annoying here and him it does not
want to trade this bishop I think rather
play Bishop c2 and then maybe night c4
he has to bring the bishop bag not sure
this actually oh now I'm not thinking
about this move follow you give me the
bishop pair for nothing I would take it
and there's still this even a pawn
weakness there that's a surprising
discern that he gives me his his best
piece there
[Music]
yeah yeah so we can so take with the
Queen doesn't look too bad centralizing
the Queen okay yeah that opening wasn't
a big success here for white so he tries
to check here but you get he cannot take
it as Bishop a fade
and my dark squares could be weak though
okay maybe not maybe not it looks good
though ma'am tricky situation yeah okay
come on I think he has to take that on
it seven otherwise and the position just
sucks push-up f8 Queen back Bishop a
three and then play on the dark squares
they are weak I mean they're really
reasons why I hesitated for so long
[Music]
they're really weak why did i do that i
actually did not see how quick this
comes we should age 60 okay it was very
very stupid again yeah i can just play
whatever you have to just out given b7
and whites position is strategically
almost lost i have the bishop pair
better send a better Queen and so on and
so on and so on completely unnecessary
now anyway position might still be okay
but i had had much i had a much better
position okay earlier so m yo
detect instead of this and queen bee
three
he has to also watch out now that's not
good I can take now him and Jose has to
watch out for the back rank and he
didn't do that white resigns yeah it's
too late valium and there's absolutely
no reason to take allow him to take on e
7 justice to that stupid the position is
more or less winning strategically hem
with any normal move Bishop f6 is what
the engine gives black has two bishops
weakness weakness weakness and tons of
awkward pieces so that some a terrible
position for white simply and yeah this
is this is just not good gem may have
compensation for a pony of it this is
what I wanted to do and this is just
crazy yeah crazy to allow this kind of
thing yeah I can just play the position
its compensation because the position
was fantastic with without a porn down
but yeah this is this is already more or
less done I'm threatening won't be too
and the week back rank and so on yeah
what you absolutely cannot do is allow
me to take on v3 here Bishop c2 is just
the only move this is this nothing else
you have to preserve this piece and this
is this is a very bad position for white
already ok guys thanks for watching